I'm Bruce Colkebeck and I'm an assistant scout master with
troop 442 in Salisbury, North Carolina. This edition of
Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, scout master,
We decided that we should get a water buffalo- That's a big,
flexible water tank called a water buffalo- for our troop. So
we went and we talked to the scouts about raising the
money to buy the water buffalo and our senior patrol
leader said: Hey, we don't need to raise money, We just
need two hydrogen buffalos and one oxygen buffalo. Don't
blame me for that one, please. That was from Tony
Lacaba, who's an assistant scout master with troop 581 in
Bristow, Virginia. Thanks, Tony, I think. Hey, this is
podcast number 295.. Hey,
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green
Looking in the mailbag.
Oh, my goodness,
Let's see.
We heard from Sergei Stretzky, who is in Illinois,
And Sergei wrote in to say:
I am 20 years old.
I was born and raised in Eastern Europe, in Ukraine.
As a child I was in the Scout Organization Plast
for eight years.
I now live in Illinois
and I miss going camping and having adventures.
I always like to go to the mountains and go boating.
I have a great traveling experience,
survival skills and first aid skills.
I wanna meet some Scouts and get a taste of adventure again.
Hey, if you're in Illinois and you're a Scouter
and you can help Sergei out, get in touch with me. huh,
He should be getting back to me
with a little bit more of an exact location
than just the state of Illinois,
but I'm sure we can get you connected there. Sergei
Gregory Matasio is in Nairobi, Kenya.
He says greetings from the Scouts in Nairobi.
I'm humbled to come across your site.
I am a Rover Scout and a facilitator too,
at the Westlands Scouts Local Association
under the umbrella of Kenya Scouts Association,
And my name is Rover Greg.
Well, Rover Greg, I'm so happy you got in touch
and we look forward to talking to you in the future.
Will Hartzell is an assistant scout master
in Honolulu, Hawaii,
And Will wrote to say aloha,
thanks for all you do for so many people
and for helping make Scouting the greatest,
most important and most meaningful organization
on planet Earth.
I've been a silent follower of yours for some time now
and enjoy your articles very much.
I helped to start Troop 777 here in Honolulu four years ago
and I've been an assistant scout master since that time.
It is likely I'll become the next scout master
within a month and will certainly take the opportunity
to dig deeper into your articles
and seek guidance for this exciting new role.
Well, Will, I'm so happy to hear from you.
I'm glad you're finding what we're doing useful
and I'm happy to dispense just a boatload
of useful advice- or, okay, just advice-
to anybody who is taking on their role as scout master.
Good for you.
This next message- I'll keep the center anonymous
because it was a question that we addressed
in last week's podcast. but they wrote in to say:
I just listened to podcast number 294..
I think you nailed it.
You were very perceptive there
And what this listener is writing about
is what we dealt with about being a cooperative volunteer
in last week's podcast.
If you haven't heard it, you can go back and listen to it.
It's pretty easy to do:
Go to scoutmastercgcom,
look for podcast number 294, Cooperative Volunteering.
Anyway, they went on to say: you know, it's funny,
I didn't really have the idea that I was gonna be taking
over or being negative to other scouts.
I think that the scouts I'm talking about
are probably getting it mostly right.
What I wanted to do was be constructive
and tweak a small point or two here or there.
But while listening to your podcast
I kind of woke up to realize that you're right.
You're seeing something I didn't.
Even though I'm trying to be constructive
and being critical or negative wasn't my intention,
I do understand that it's buried there just a little bit.
It certainly would come off more of that way
to the scouts who I'm talking about.
So I think you addressed it very well
and thank you for opening my eyes.
Well, you know, when you go into a situation
and your intentions are very positive
and you wanna be constructive,
you can be successful in doing that. certainly,
The whole thing is developing that relationship
before you start offering constructive criticisms. right,
And that's basically what we were talking about last week.
So I'm glad that was useful for you.
Last week we had a couple of really great
lively chat sessions.
We have live chat sessions at scoutmastercgcom
Usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
If you keep an eye on our Facebook feed
and our Twitter feed, they'll alert you to when
I'm going to be there alive,
and a lot of folks check in from all over the place.
I call them our frequent flyers.
but this past week we also got to chat with Stephen Thuler,
who is a new scoutmaster in Logan, Utah.
Thanks for checking in, Stephen.
Come over and join us on the live chat.
It's great fun.
Before I go any further this week,
I wanna ask you a favor.
Thousands of scouts all 50 states
and 31 other countries actually listen
into the Scoutmaster podcast
And I depend on listeners support
to keep the podcast on the air,
to help with the cost of producing and publishing
everything we do at scoutmastercgcom.
Now, if you'll go to scoutmastercgcom
and click the support link at the top of the page,
you'll find many options that fit every budget
to help support this work,
And you can also get autographed copies of my books.
by doing so,
You can join hundreds of fellow scouts
who generously support the blog, the podcast
and all the resources that are freely available
to scouts all over the world at scoutmastercgcom.
Do that this week and I will personally thank you
during next week's podcast.
Well, in this week's podcast
we've got a couple of email questions to answer
and there's no reason we can't get started.
So let's get started, shall we?
10,, nine, eight, seven,
Six, five, four, three,
Two, one.
Let's start the fun.
Find me a letter,
Send it by name.
Email, that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
This is an email I got recently said this:
We recently had a ceremony for a scout
who had turned 18 years old without becoming an Eagle Scout
but was going to move on to become an adult volunteer.
Several people mentioned to me in passing
that it was a terrible shame that the scout never got Eagle.
And it was a terrible shame that the scout never got Eagle
And kind of thought it was a terrible waste of time.
I thought they were dead wrong
and I felt a little insulted.
Scout I'm talking about has done a lot of really great things,
is really a great guy, spent a lot of time in scouts,
wasn't very interested in becoming an Eagle
And to call what he did in scouting a waste of time
bothers me a little bit.
If we're just concentrating on getting Eagle,
we're missing the fact that there's a whole lot more
a young person you can get out of scouting
Down the road. another troop just awarded a 13-year-old Eagle
And there were high fives and kudos passed around.
But I beg to ask you which scouting career was more successful.
Well, I'm going to agree with you almost.
oh, I guess maybe about 80%,
And my answer might sound a little snotty
And I apologize if it does.
I guess it just kind of comes with the territory sometimes,
But really no,
I'm intending this in the best way possible.
First, people have this overblown attitude
towards becoming an Eagle,
And I get that.
I wish they would understand that there are a lot of scouts
who can get a great deal out of scouting
without ever wanting to become an Eagle Scout.
You know, it's a great achievement, sure,
But not everybody's interested in it.
And if people don't get it-
but not everybody's interested in it,
And if people did understand that
they wouldn't stand around and kind of say under the breath,
wow, it's just a dirty shame,
and boy didn't get to be an Eagle Scout.
Maybe he wasn't interested,
Maybe it meant nothing to him,
Maybe what was important to him,
what he was doing in scouts.
But I got to tell you, friend,
you're kind of doing the same thing
in trying to draw a comparison between this scout
and the 13-year-old Eagle Scout,
Because it kind of sounds like
you think the 13-year-old Eagle Scout
wasn't as successful as this scout.
And this was what really takes me to the part
where I'm going to be a little snotty. okay,
These kind of comparisons,
these apple and orange comparisons,
aren't proper in any way that we do them.
You're asking me to give you an opinion
based on two incomparable things,
And at the heart of that matter
lies a whole lot of things. that kind of dog us in scouting.
You know in the way that we look at things
and the way we consider things.
So let me explain myself.
In drawing a comparison between those two scouts,
you're kind of asking which is the best fruit,
an orange or an apple?
Now, I like oranges, okay,
But you know, not all that often
Apples are great.
I probably like them more. all right,
To be honest with you,
I don't know about you,
but if somebody offered me the choice
of an apple or an orange,
I'd probably take the apple seven times out of ten,
unless I was kind of in an orange mood,
if you know what I'm talking about.
Now, if somebody else chose the orange,
well, I wouldn't get all worked up about it
and try to explain why the apple was so much better,
because I don't have to eat what they chose, right,
I get to eat my apple.
Now, no matter how hard you try to make
every apple or orange the same as all the others,
each one's got to be a little bit different, right?
It'd be pretty boring eating identical apples
or oranges all the time. anyway,
No matter how hard you try,
you can't make an apple into an orange
or vice versa.
So that kind of leads to the question:
are all scouts the same?
No, they're not,
Not by a long shot, right?
Are all eagle scouts exactly the same?
No, they're not,
Not by a long shot.
Do I care if a scout achieves eagle?
No, actually not really.
I mean, it's something great to do,
but not everybody's all that interested in it.
Do I care how old a scout is
when they achieve eagle?
No, I don't.
Well, look honestly, really I do.
I would prefer they were younger
than 17 years, 11 months and 28 days,
but you know, I've learned
that you don't always get what you want. okay,
You know I serve three or four more times
as long as a scout master than most people do.
Does that make me something special?
No, not really.
I just manage to stay around longer,
That's all
I mean. you see where I'm headed here.
The kind of comparisons that we often draw
as scouters is- wait for it-
apples and oranges.
They're just things that they're.
well, I love it. a good idiom, okay.
And the idiom of comparing apples to oranges
refers to the apparent differences
between things that are incomparable
or inco-measurable.
It's a false analogy, like saying
an apple is not a good orange.
And I love a good idiom
And this one's a doozy right.
You know, in much of Europe
when they use this idiom
they say apples and pears,
And in Latin America
it's potatoes and sweet potatoes,
Believe it or not. in Serbia, okay,
They say comparing grandmothers and toads.
In Romania they compare cows to longjons.
The Welsh compare honey and butter,
And there's a Danish idiom that I really like:
What is highest,
A roundtower or a thunderclap?
In Russia they compare warm and soft.
In Poland they ask
what is gingerbread to a widnall?
I mean really,
Rather than asking
who's the most successful scout,
How about if we ask
if that particular young person
got something out of being a scout?
There's no comparison in the scout oath.
It only uses personal pronouns.
On my honor,
I will do my best.
So when people want to draw comparisons like this,
or they want to say:
you know, this guy didn't get eagle
and compared to the other guys that got eagle,
well, that's kind of a waste.
It's a dirty shame that he did.
Oh, come on people,
Really No.
How about we guide our scouts
to evaluate themselves against themselves
On my honor.
I will do my best,
Not everybody else's best.
I'm going to do the best that I can possibly do.
Wouldn't that be good?
I mean, isn't that a more useful thing
to be able to do?
Isn't that a more useful life skill?
How about we get them in the habit of doing that?
I think that would keep our eye more on the ball,
don't you think?
And we can leave the immeasurable comparisons
of apples and oranges and toads
and grandmothers and all that kind of thing
to somebody else.
This next email came to me from Brian Kerner.
Pretty quick question:
Can a scout hold the same position of responsibility
from first class all the way through life rank?
I'm not saying it's a good practice,
I'm just curious if it's allowed.
Well, Brian, these kind of questions come up
from time to time
and it's really easy to get an answer for it.
I don't even have to really tell you the answer,
because the answer is in the requirement.
If there was such a restriction-
if, for instance, a scout could not be credited
for the same position of responsibility
for different ranks- it would very clearly say so
within the requirement.
So let's talk about this for a moment.
Positions of responsibility are all listed
in the requirements for first class
star, life and eagle.
The list is a little bit different for eagle,
but it's the same for first class
star and life.
There is a number of months of tenure
you have to serve successfully
in a position of responsibility to qualify
for those ranks,
And those months can be served
non-consecutively.
They can be served in one position
or in a combination of positions of responsibility.
So there you have it.
It's really pretty simple,
but it's a good question
and I appreciate getting it.
Thanks, Brian.
Hey, if you have a question for me,
you can get in touch.
It's pretty easy to do
and you're going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks so much for listening
to this 295th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's different ways you can keep in touch. okay,
Read the blog at scoutmasterscgcom
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can experience all that we do
through the vast panorama of social media.
That's right.
Join the 11,000 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
Tweet along with the chorus
1,300 tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the Pultritudinous pictures
We proffer publicly
with 2,400 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch us at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
but wait, wait, wait.
You say no, no, no,
I can't face Facebook,
and Twitter makes me bitter.
I have no interest in Pinterest.
I do not put the? U in YouTube,
That's all right. monkey,
Just zoom into the late 90s
and fire off a good old-fashioned email.
You can get in touch with me, Clark Green
at Clark at scoutmastercgcom-
C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom,
And, if all else fails,
find a bright red phone with no dial,
and it's usually on the commissioner's desk
under a glass dome.
Press the button and I'll answer.
By now, it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not sponsored or endorsed
by any scouting organization,
including the Boy Scouts of America,
and that it's really just me.
Somebody gave me access
to the microphone and the internet,
and here I am right,
trying to help my fellow scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun,
here is our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.